He only was removed from office or
resigned from office a few months ago,
a formidable prime minister and the
formidable politician,
and I suspect the Labour Party will
regret removing men,
a very middle class Britain
with a w taken over a very strong
economy and he'd left the same strong
economy.
He made some genuinely very brilliant
reforms and his record will bear
watching what has saddened,
uh,
what blocked that record or harm it is
Iraq.
The fact that he was so willing to look
to some of us just fall in line with
President Bush,
I think Margaret Thatcher would have
stood up to President Bush and said so
far and no further.
And if you take away Iraq,
which you can't from the legacy,
uh,
it's a very impressive premiership,
but he will be settled historically.
He will be saddled with Iraq.